more reaction to the chauvin verdict
first uh
here's someone on msnbc explaining why
even though they got everything they
want
they're still very very unhappy
shockingly let's listen
i actually always thought that he would
be found guilty because it's sort of a
cultural makeup call
but i'm not happy i'm not pleased i
don't have any sense of satisfaction i
don't think this is a system working
i don't think this is a good thing what
this says to me
is that in order to get a nominal degree
of justice in this country
that a black man has to be murdered on
air viewed by the entire world there
have to be a year's worth of protests
and a phalanx of other white police
officers to tell one white officer that
he was wrong in order to get
one scintilla of justice notice okay
he's not he's not happy of course the
left we know that they're never they're
never happy
um the revolution continues and they
also assume he says yeah
i knew there'd be a guilty verdict they
assume they're going to get what they
want
and they do most of the time but you're
never going to be
satisfied that's why i think
i've always thought the label
progressivism it fits
now you might not like when you when you
think of what what the left is doing
i don't really consider it progress but
it is pro it's progress in the way that
cancer progresses in that sort of way
it just keeps moving and infecting and
growing
and left-wing progressivism is the same
way never it never
gets to a point where it's satisfied and
says all right i've i've had enough
just keep moving to the next thing keep
moving on
um so he's not happy obviously but
notice how
he he admits basically admits
that this verdict was uh partly the
product of the pressure put on the jury
he says it right there he says that what
we needed to have a year of protests and
all this stuff in order to get that
that that quote unquote justice
he's admitting he's admitting that the
jury at least partially from his
perspective
came to this conclusion because that's
what that's the pressure that was put on
them
aoc had i think we had this clip she had
a similar take let's let's play that
it's not justice and i'll explain to you
why it's not justice
it's not justice because justice
is george floyd going home tonight
to be with his family justice
is adam toledo
getting tucked in by his mom tonight
justice is when you're pulled over
they're not being a gun that's part of
that interaction
because you have a headlight out what is
that supposed to refer to
a gun's not part of that interaction
well if you're talking about dante
wright the reason the gun's part of the
interaction
is because you um committed armed
robbery
against a woman and there was a warrant
for your arrest
and they tried to arrest you and you
resisted that that's how the gun got
involved there
this is not i i will agree though aside
from that last part the rest of it
i sort of agree this is not justice
this verdict is not just because it's
the result of
of pressure
this is this is really it's the death of
the rule of law
where the left knows that it can get
someone convicted of murder
if it wants but i thought of all you
know
and we could sit here all day playing
the reaction from the left in the media
to the shove and trial and
and most of it is exactly what you would
expect this is also what you would
expect but um
it's also perhaps the most demented
reaction this is from nancy pelosi
not you what she's saying here is not
unique and not the first time she said
something like this
but here she is fully embracing the
religious
cult-like nature of of of all of this
and of the whole
quote-unquote anti-racism movement um
here she is appointing
george floyd a christ-like messianic
figure who dies for the sins of
of all mankind or at least of of white
mankind um
here's here here she is thank you george
floyd
for sacrificing your life for justice
for being there to call out to your mom
how
how heartbreaking was that call out for
your mom
i can't breathe but because of you and
because of
thousands millions of people around the
world who came out
for justice your name will always be
synonymous
with justice good lord you know what i
actually had not listened to that full
clip until right now because i could
barely stomach it
all i heard was thank you george george
floyd for sacrificing your life
sacrificing your life for all of us it's
not an exaggeration this
this is what christians say about jesus
christ
they've appointed george floyd their
their christ their messiah in this
religious cult
which which has the the hallmarks in
every sense of of of a religion
as we've talked about original it has
there's always the concept of original
sin
um only we know in the christian faith
original sin is shared by everyone
um in this case it is uh it is a racial
original sin
white people have it we pass it down i
guess in our bloodline this guilt
but where she she says there your name
will always be
synonymous with justice
i you know every time i hear something
like that i i can't help but
but think to and i don't even know her
name or what she looks like
and that's the point but
but imagine being the woman who who
george floyd
robbed didn't just rob but it
forced his way into her house put a gun
to her and robbed her
another one of the guys in his crew
pistol-whipped her
so you've just you've been robbed and
pistol-whipped in your own home by
george floyd and his crew
that happened a few years ago and uh and
now you have to hear
nancy pelosi saying that his name is
synonymous with justice
imagine if the if the christ figure that
your culture has
selected is the guy who forced his way
into your home and robbed you
but no nobody cares about her her she is
literally nameless and faceless in
as far as the public and the public goes
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated